remember that time Seattle socialist
City Councilmember Shaw Misawa pressed
for the city to increase its minimum
wage to $15 per hour
I actually debated some ones on the
issue I asked her if she'd be in favor
of raising the minimum wage to $1,000
per hour
she misdirected obviously Seattle
actually ended up embracing $13 per hour
raising the minimum wage from 947 in
2014 to 11 bucks in 2015 to 13 bucks in
2016 under the theory that an increase
wouldn't throw people out of work
wouldn't encourage part-time hiring and
would inflate salaries enough to allow
more affordability in the Seattle
housing market a new study demonstrates
that as usual central planning of the
economy leads to precisely the reverse
of the results the plan of the central
planners seek to achieve according to a
new paper from the National Bureau of
Economic Research quote using a variety
of methods to analyze employments in all
sectors paying below a specified real
hourly wage we conclude that the second
way to increase the 13 bucks reduced
hours worked in low-wage jobs by around
9 percent while hourly wages in such
jobs increased by only around three
percent consequently total payroll fell
for such jobs implying that the minimum
wage ordinance lowered low-wage
employees earnings by an average of 125
dollars per month in 2016 private
Institute's more modest effect to the
first wage increase we estimate an
effect of zero when analyzing employment
in the restaurant industry at all wage
levels comparable to many prior studies
in other words restaurants didn't fire
anybody they just put them on part-time
shifts and cut back their hours that
shouldn't be a surprise since that's
exactly what happens every time the
government places an extra burden on
employers one of the great myths of
minimum wage movement and the central
planning movement as a whole is that
business owners aren't operating in a
slim margin but raking in dollars to
hide in their Scrooge McDuck money bins
depleting the potential income of their
employees that's not true
thanks to competition and competition is
fierce in industries that employ minimum
wage workers profit margins are never
enormous even in 2013 a booming year for
the restaurant business Capital IQ
estimated the average profit margin for
restaurants at 2.4 percent profitability
varies by chain as well and by local
franchise even leftist were taken aback
by Seattle's sizable minimum wage
increase Jared Bernstein of the leftist
Center on Budget and Policy Priorities
derided the minimum wage increases in
Seattle as quote beyond moderate extreme
in other words but he admitted you don't
know what the outcome is going to
you have to test it you have to
scrutinize it which is why Seattle's a
great test case or you could leave the
market alone since testing markets by
cramming down intervention ISM puts
people out of work at least part-time
here are the facts
Seattle barely had any jobs under the
$11 threshold before the legislation
passed but that wasn't true of $13 an
hour jobs and the regulations
essentially priced a good deal of
full-time low-wage labor out of the
market
furthermore the economy right now in
Seattle is strong what happens during a
downturn when businesses have to shed
costs government intervention isn't the
answer to the free market the free
market is the answer to the free market
but don't expect the left to admit
they're not merely punishing evil
businessman they're skewing the entire
labor market and hurting a broad swath
of people including minimum wage
employees i'm ben shapiro this is the
venture hero show
so many things to talk about the Supreme
Court has come down with a number of
rulings today some are really good some
are really not so good we'll talk about
all of them plus the media are
desperately upset about the fact that
the Trump Russia collusion thing is
falling apart Democrats don't know how
to handle it either and we'll talk about
Trump care but before we get to any of
that we first have to say thank you to
our sponsors over at textured calm so
this is a service that I just love
instead of having to subscribe to a
bajillion different magazines and pay a
separate fee for each instead of having
to subscribe to The New Yorker time the
Atlantic Vanity Fair instead you get
them all in one app called texture with
texture you get access to 200 plus
magazines full of in-depth interviews
and stories all in that texture app
right there on your tablet or phone
right now if you go to texture comm
slash pen you get a 14-day free trial
when you go to texture calm so that's
been it's normally $9.99 a month and you
get 200 magazines so you know for what
you'd be paying for probably two
magazines you're getting 200 but if you
sign up right now at texture comm slash
Bend you get a 14-day free trial to get
access to all of their back catalogue my
wife gets reader side just through
texture I get Sports Illustrated again
sometimes through texture but you don't
have to subscribe to any one magazine
instead all you have to do is check out
all of them at once right you get access
to all of these magazines we're talking
National Geographic Vanity Fair Rolling
Stone cosmopolitan Time magazine People
magazine it's just fantastic if you're
addicted to information texture comm is
for you texture comm slash Ben you get
that 14-day free trial again that is
texture calm slash Ben a texture app is
just fantastic it was selected as one of
Apple's top 2016 iPad apps and for good
reason start that free trial now and
you'll enjoy so much I promise they'll
keep coming back texture calm /ban use
the flash pen also so they know that we
sent you and they continue to advertise
with the program okay so let's begin
with the big news of the day which is
that president Trump's travel ban has
largely been upheld at the Supreme Court
level so from the Supreme Court issued a
ruling on Monday morning that would
grant petitions for certiorari and
grants day applications in part on
president Trump's travel ban so
basically here's what happened President
Trump had his travel ban his travel ban
said that he was going to ban travel for
indefinitely from these six majority
Muslim countries and put a 90-day hold
immigration so that he could get a
better handle on vetting procedures that
90-day period has basically expired by
now and we're supposed to get a plan any
time now but the travel ban was designed
really to prevent the importation of
Syrian refugees it was designed to
prevent the importation of people from
countries like Yemen where we don't know
anything about the people and the courts
lower courts you recall had ruled that
this was improper that it was
discrimination based on religion which
is asinine because again you do not have
constitutional rights if you live
outside the United States and are not a
United States citizen a green card
holder so these are some random dude on
a hilltop in Yemen you do not have the
right to enter the country and you'll
recall the rulings were so stupid that
they went back to the campaign and they
quoted Trump's tweets and they said
really what this is it's an
impermissible attempt to ban Islam well
now it gets to the Supreme Court level
and the Supreme Court says listen we'll
have a full hearing on the travel ban in
October but for now all these lower
court rulings are really done so the
court consolidated the various cases on
the travel ban for hearing in October
and the court relieved temporary
injunctions issued by those lower courts
regarding people attempting to enter the
country who quote lack any vota fide
relationship with people with a person
or entity in the United States so there
were two types of people who had filed
injunctions against this particular
travel ban injunction is seeking person
number one was the guy who has a
mother-in-law in Yemen and he wants her
to come in from Yemen so the court says
that person still has an injunction so
that person can still bring
mother-in-law in but the people who did
not get an injunction are the university
so universities sued and they said well
if we can't draw from Yemen then we're
really going to just destroy the
diversity of our universities we need
more people from Yemen who are unvetted
otherwise how the hell are we going to
staff up this engineering department
it's always a silly argument but the
courts basically said this is a super
silly argument because you may think you
have an interest in bringing in unvetted
immigration but that the government has
the power over immigration you don't and
so you can't just say random person from
Yemen who might or might not apply means
to come into the country so that we can
let them in that's not the way that this
works so effectively this means the
court tossed the cases brought by the
universities but left in place specific
injunctions against preventing
importation of relatives of American
citizens from abroad so basically
Trump's travel ban has been
indicated in the main there's no
standing for the vast majority of people
who are suing the travel ban is probably
going to remain even the leftist judges
didn't have much to say about Oh Trump
is obviously in Islamophobe and that's
what all this is about
so Trump ends up with win on the travel
ban a bit of a surprise result given the
fact that all the lower courts had been
using this as a club to wield against
Trump now there are a lot of people
today who are saying that just to score
such on the Supreme Court is the swing
vote in a lot of these cases he is not
swing vote in virtually any of these
cases so he replaced Justice Scalia
obviously the swing vote is still
justice Kennedy in the vast majority of
these cases so that was case number one
very very good for the Trump
administration that is a win for the
Trump administration there rightly
crawling about it today as well they
should because the lower courts are
ridiculous the lower courts were always
ridiculous so good for the Trump
administration for standing by its
second executive order and good for the
court mostly for ignoring all of the
stupidity of the lower courts so that is
ruling number one that was that was the
big news this morning then there is
ruling number two this one is also good
news but not quite as good news as some
people on the right are saying this is a
ruling 72 and that says that states
cannot prohibit public funding to
churches simply because their churches
so in this case there's a case
surrounding a playground at Trinity
Lutheran Child Church child Learning
Center over in Mississippi and there's a
law on the books in Mississippi that
said that churches cannot apply for
public funding because of separation of
church and state the Supreme Court says
you can't discriminate against churches
that way if the funding is available to
everyone just because there's a
religious institution or person that
doesn't mean that you can discriminate
against that religious institution or
person the opinion was delivered by
Chief Justice Roberts it would have
concurrences by Justice Thomas and
Gorsuch only the far left justice
Sotomayor and Ginsburg the sentence that
means the kennedy and even Kagan voted
on behalf of the idea that churches
should be allowed to receive public
money for a playground which is what
this was this church applied for a
rubberized playground where the state
said no even though you're a good
applicant we're not going to allow you
because you're Church and so the court
said no you're not allowed to do that
the the keyline and the decision says
the exclusion of Trinity Lutheran from a
public benefit for which it is otherwise
qualified solely because it is a church
is odious Torrance
and cannot stand so there is a so people
are very excited about this case there
are a couple things that make me less
excited about the case one there's
significant limitation on the cases
scope so footnote three to this kit this
case is a bizarre footnote and it says
this case really only applies to
playground resurfacing so it doesn't
apply to anything else doesn't apply to
for example your church you want public
funding for a for a religious outreach
program or even easier you want school
vouchers so that you can fund student
education and it's part of that
education there's some religious
education the Court did not rule on that
and the court refused to rule on that
which is a problem because the court
should rule on that there's a very easy
obvious thing if couches are available
to you to go wherever you want why
should we exclude religious institutions
from that judge courses just concurrence
hits on precisely this point is the
court leaves open the possibility a
useful distinction might be drawn
between laws that discriminate on the
basis of religious status and religious
use respectfully I harbored doubts about
the stability of such a line instead a
religious group that built the
playground or did a group build a
playground so it might be used to
advance a religious mission
so again Gorsuch is main concern here
because the court is going to come back
with school vouchers and say well sure
we don't really want to discriminate
against churches but the church is
trying to push religion and we can't
foster the church and pushing religion
so no school vouchers that's what the
court is leaving the door open to
Gorsuch says and this is the this is the
most important line of his concurrence
of course which by the way is terrific
he said listen he's so true I said he
was terrific at the time I mean as soon
as Trump appointed I wore a freaking
Magda hat on the show
borage says the Constitution quote
guarantees the free exercise of religion
not just the right to in word belief
generally the government may not force
people to choose between participation
in a public program and the right to
free exercise of religion I don't see
what it should matter whether we
describe that benefit say as close to
Lutheran's by status or close to people
who do Lutheran things by use it is free
exercise either way there's also another
issue that is related and that's because
the Supreme Court's about to take it up
so the Supreme Court is about to take up
another case and this is the gay Baker
the gay wedding cake case right so
there's a bakery that is in Colorado
that will not cater a gay wedding and
the Colorado government has
tried to persecute that bakery and the
Baker's say well that's a violation of
our freedom of religion so Gorsuch is
concerned and you can see that he's
concerned that the court is about to
decide whether businesses can operate in
a religious manner congruent with free
exercise if they don't serve gay couples
cakes for example so gorgeous gorgeous
point is that the court is leaving the
door open to arguing that a state is not
discriminating against a religious
person but only against doing religious
things right so just like in this case
the court is saying well the church was
not doing a religious thing so they can
apply for the grant they would also say
well you know when you operate a bakery
you're not doing a religious thing and
therefore we can crack down on you that
is dangerous logic because the fact is
that religion does pervade all the
things that religious people do okay
here is the fact as a religious person
everything I do in my life is pervaded
by a certain religious sensibility and
mission okay because that's true of
everyone who's religious if you're a
secularist then you're motivating
ideology of secularism and what you do
is motivated by your second secularism
if you're a religious person especially
if you're a practicing Jew for example
every time you eat every time you serve
food every time you say thanks and grace
for serving food you know does that mean
that you are now doing something that is
forbidden or at least the government can
bar because it's religious activity I'm
not I'm not discriminating against you
as a religious person I'm just saying
you can't be religious outside of the
church that doesn't wash and that's what
Gorsuch is saying the left by the way
would like to steamroll all religious
practice into private justice kagan is
trying to say well running a playground
isn't religious anyway so it's a moot
point but the pedal is going to hit the
metal when it comes to actual religious
beliefs dictating how you behave which
is true of the vast majority of
religious people ok so then there is a
third Supreme Court case and this one's
getting a lot less attention but this
one is just totally crazy so on Monday
the Supreme Court declared that birth
certificates we're no longer designed to
list the biological parents of children
so over in Arkansas they had a law that
says that a married husband and wife or
the biological parents of a child are
listed on the birth certificate the
reason a married couple husband and wife
are listed on the birth certificate is
because they are presumably the
biological parents of the child and
because of that there's a provision in
Arkansas law that says that if there's
artificial insemination we
can we make an exception and we allow
the non-biological parents but the the
married parents should be listed on the
birth certificate now there's a couple
of lesbian couples and they got their
birth certificates they were able to
list their names on the birth
certificates under the artificial
insemination portion of the law right
they were allowed to that Parshin of law
that applied only to men and women was
struck down they said that this is it's
obvious that if we can list non
biological parents for artificial
insemination we will do that for
heterosexual couples and for gay couples
but that wasn't enough for the lesbian
couples lesbian couples we wanted to get
their birth certificates not under the
guise of the artificial insemination
criteria but under the guise instead of
normal biological parenting ideas so the
state of Arkansas rightly pointed out
that the state of Arkansas had already
issued valid birth certificates listing
each child's biological mother and her
spouse and then the artificial
insemination statute applied to same-sex
couples but that wasn't enough so
Arkansas based on the rules of human
biology had determined that heterosexual
spouses were typically the biological
parents of their children in fact in
Arkansas quote where a court determines
that someone besides the spouse is a
child's father or alternatively the
mother husband and putative father a
test that the putative father is the
child's biological father that putative
biological father must be listed on a
child's birth certificate so if they
find out in a court proceeding or
something that the child does not be put
to the portunity of the child is in
question
they actually list the biological father
why because the purpose of a birth
certificate is not just a marriage
certificate it is not a legal
guardianship certificate a birth
certificate is designed so they a child
can later go back and look up who are
the biological parents that is the
purpose why because for example my good
friend Andrew Breitbart right when he
died it turned out that he had a
congenital heart defect well he would
have known that if he had looked at
presumably as California birth
certificate which supposedly was
supposed to list not just his mom but
also his debt I don't know if it listed
his dad we didn't know whose dad was
presumably his dad had some sort of
congenital heart defect one of the
purposes of having a birth certificate
is that children can go back and look at
the health issues that impacted their
parents and that is one of the reasons
for birth certificate but the court says
no it hurts the feelings of gay people
and therefore we have to issue birth
certificates to same-sex spouses
regardless of biological parentage
under the artificial insemination
statute but under the general birth
certificate statute so birth
certificates are basically just another
legal guardianship document now or a
second marriage certificate with a kid's
name on it
justices Gorsuch Alito and Thomas the
three conservatives on the court they
dissented as they as well they should
have one of the things I hate just as a
general note is I hate these these term
ending decisions it's just monarchic
it's it's aristocratic and I hate it
this idea that the Supreme Court gets to
sit there on high and then determine
you're right and my rights is really
stupid we talked about the issue of
judicial review and the idea of this
infallible Supreme Court we discussed
that a couple of weeks ago on big ideas
on Thursday but the fact is that there's
a much better case the Legislature
should be allowed to do more and the
Supreme Court should be allowed to do
less rather than we sit around and wait
to hear whether Justice Kennedy took his
brand this morning which is basically
with the Supreme Court amounts to this
monarchic crap where all of the media
outlets line up to get the dicta from
the Supreme Court to get the opinions
from the Supreme Court and they line up
and then they just wait eagerly to hear
what these all wise beings have to say
about the Constitution there's a reason
that separate officers of the court and
of the legislature and the president all
sorta note to the Constitution that is
that the Constitution was not supposed
to be the sole repository of the Supreme
Court unfortunately that's what it has
become okay so before we continue here I
want to talk about the media's
frustration with the fact that Trump is
continuing to get some policy things
done like now he's actually starting to
do to get some policy things done at
least the travel ban was now upheld by
the Supreme Court
it looks like Trump care is going to
move through the Senate and the media is
frustrated because they don't know how
to handle all this like Trump is
unpopular but then understand why that
isn't stopping the EPA from rolling back
regulations we'll talk about that in
just a second but before we do that I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Zeile so Zeile is a fantastic
service Co if you need a massage right
now you download the seal app or you go
to zeal comm and what they do is they
make sure that a licensed masseuse comes
to your house they bring the table they
bring the music they need them they
bring the massage oils you schedule it
yourself you prepay it is seven days a
week 365 days a year as ill massage
therapists can be at your door and as
little as an hour privacy convenience
quality and comfort
he'll calm or does he live phone or
Android app that deal is his EEE l and
you select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists choose
your favorite technique your gender
preference time location for your
massage bring this body you try zeal
today there on demand we've used it at
my house I've used zeal my wife has use
deal
my parents of use deal my sister is use
deal my mother-in-law has use deal that
was a great present we were supposed to
get a zeal massage and I just gave it to
my mother-in-law definitely made our
relationship a lot better she'll calm is
fantastic it's a great gift for people z
ee l calm right now to help you get
started you get $25 off your first
massage like a quarter off your first
massage by using the promo code Benton
checkout it's cheaper more convenient
than a spa it gets better if you sign up
for that deal massage membership then
you get 20% off all your massages plus a
free massage table and sheet set which
is a $380 value yours free there's no
initiation fee to join the membership
just terrific savings on top of the $25
discount you're going to get when you
use promo code bent so go to zeal GTL
calm or on teals iPhone or Android app
use that promo code been at checkout get
$25 off your first in-home on-demand
massage again they have 8,000 masseuses
all across the nation all of them
licensed it's just fantastic super
convenient great gift zeal calm and use
that promo code then okay so the media
is obviously frustrated because despite
all of their focus on Trump Russia they
haven't been able to stop anything
and it's funny three weeks ago when
there was a lot of news about Comey and
Trump Russia and all this stuff and Fox
News was ignoring the news then the
ratings for Fox News went down CNN
lately has been ignoring the real news
that's happening in the universe in
order to continue to focus on Trump
Russia and their ratings are now down
the rule of the story is is we here
believe at the ben shapiro show is you
cover the news you don't decide what
news is important based on who you would
like to win there is news that is
important in there's news that is not
important and that news remains
important despite your own political
partisan interest CNN doesn't understand
that so CNN is very frustrated they're
very angry because Fox and Friends had
an interview with Trump and granted it's
a typical Fox and Friends interview it's
just a softball interview with President
Trump brian Stelter CNN who hates Trump
he came out and he said it's just an
infomercial the bottom line you might
look at this
and see propaganda from Fox I prefer to
think of it as an infomercial Fox &
Friends is selling a product of course
it's in the guise of a news talk show
just like something on QVC or HSN or all
those channels now it's a free country
but viewers should recognize what
product Fox is selling
okay so obviously brian Stelter very
very upset about this of course all of
us here on the right were saying well
where were you for eight years while the
media was just puckering up for Obama I
mean here's a flashback montage of just
some of the questions that Obama was
asked during his time as president you
racked up a lot of wins in the last few
weeks that a lot of people thought would
be difficult to come by are you ready to
call yourself the comeback kid it seems
that you've built up some political
capital for the remaining months of your
presidency I'm curious how you want to
use it what hard things do you want to
tackle at this point during these first
100 days what has surprised you the most
about this office enchanted you the most
about serving in this office humbled you
the most and troubled you the most let
me represent you golf
so what does it do for you first of all
I'm terrible I'm horrible
no worst thing ever started investing
I've ever done in this fatherless world
where did you learn to love in the race
for the White House punching the
president is par for the course
Republican hopefuls take shots at mr.
Obama in their debates Barack Obama
Barack Obama is better than Barack Obama
but when President Obama is asked to
respond he often settles on this well
rehearsed line I am going to make a
practice of not commenting on whatever
is said it's crazy I mean obviously you
all remember the media bias was just
insane in favorable another man that
there's media bias in favor of Trump
because I think you have to universally
be on the anti-trump page in order to
make all this happen and that's why
they're so bewildered because after
months and months of 30 a year of
coverage almost on the Trump Russia
stuff it turns out there is nothing
there and not only is there nothing
there it turns out that the blowback is
actually affecting the guy who they love
President Obama Adam Schiff a
representative ship from out here in
California who's been hot and heavy on
the Trump Russia stuff even he is now
being forced to acknowledge that it's
Obama who blew it on the Russia
investigation that really there was a
problem of Trump Russia Obama should
have announced it much earlier they're
so mad they can't help it it's a big
problem for them and I'll explain why in
a second did Obama fail and his duty to
this nation I think the Obama
administration should have done a lot
more when it became clear that not only
was Russia intervening but it was a big
directed at the highest levels of the
Kremlin and indeed the senator Feinstein
and I were repeatedly trying to make
that case administration initially when
they didn't want to make attribution
they didn't want to publicly talk about
Russia's role and later after we issued
our own statement and they did attribute
the conduct to Russia
I was urging that they began then the
process of sanctioning Russia the
administration talking more forcefully
given the seriousness of this I think
administration need to call out Russia
earlier I needed to act to deter and
punish Russia earlier okay so now he's
mad at Obama and this is the way that
this is going to work all the way
through right so the Democrats were
talking Trump Russia Trump Russia Trump
Russia then it turns out that Obama knew
about Trump Russia and didn't say
anything about Trump Russia for two
reasons one he felt he didn't have
enough information yet supposedly and
two because he was afraid that if he
said anything it would blow back on
Hillary because there'd be suggestions
that Obama was trying to rig the
election for Hillary Clinton in any case
the Democrats are just in complete
disarray over the Trump Russia stuff but
one wing of the party has no choice but
to continue talking about I'll explain
why in a second but for that you have to
go over to Daley wired.com become a
subscriber for $8 a month you too can
become a subscriber to daily wire combat
changes July 10th by the way so if you
want to lock in that rate right now
daily wire comm become and subscriber
right now for eight dollars a month
rates are rising on July 10 out of
demand so make sure that you go and you
become a subscriber right now you can be
part of the mailbag which we do on
Fridays you can part of the live show
you can see clave ins live show be part
of his mailbag we have some other shows
that are coming which are going to be
awesome we're excited to announce those
in very near future if you can annual
subscription you know free signed copy
of this year book by me and my father
say it so Papa Dada me and the 2005
White Sox championship season all about
baseball and fathers and sons and it's
just a lot of fun you get a free signed
copy when you become an annual
subscriber right now over at daily wire
comma get and do it right now lock in
your rate so that you don't end up with
the higher rate if you try to subscribe
after July 10th rates are not changing
for people who are already subscribed so
make sure that you lock in that rate
right now check it out over daily where
common we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you